[Música]
y cordial saludo a todas y todos
bienvenidos a este programa de todos los
viernes canadá en las américas café de
radio canadá internacional un programa
que tratamos de hacerlo lo más ameno
posible también lo llamamos el castor
cibernético esta es la edición del 22 de
noviembre 23 y 24 de noviembre en vivo y
en directo en facebook live en nuestro
sitio internet en youtube y en nuestra
aplicación hoy en el estudio se
encuentran conmigo leonora chapman
paloma martínez y leonardo gimeno
venidas
[Música]
es hermoso oye hay paridad hay tres
mujeres y una parte del estudio y como
ya se dieron cuenta allá del otro lado
de la mesa tenemos invitados se trata de
mar mercado que es la directora general
de los encuentros internacionales del
documental de montreal que se está
llevando a cabo en este momento aquí en
montreal y termina el domingo próximo
mar a bienvenida muchas gracias
gracias por la invitación y carlos
ferrán zavala cineasta canadiense de
origen peruano que está presentando su
último documental o su más reciente
documental aunque documentó el carnet de
voyage carnet de viaje
que lo presenta también en los
encuentros internacionales del
documental de mostrar el bienvenido dar
los gracias por tener acá y bueno y un
cordial saludo a todos ustedes allá del
otro lado de las cámaras y del micrófono
que están acudiendo a esta cita semanal
un saludo a todos los que aman la música
porque la música del músico música
un saludo a todos
nosotros sabemos que nuestra lengua es
una lengua viva sigue creciendo
continuamente si la gente lo usa si lo
siente
los sociólogos
están los científicos sociales lo están
utilizando en sus documentos lo sigo
insistiendo en si no les gusta
el programa está perfecto ya tenemos esa
capacidad de saber cuándo pero por
ejemplo el uso le da si nosotros
empezamos todos a decir todo es de
costumbre exacto es como cuando uno dice
a ver por favor ha costado un poco la
respuesta y acostar que significa que
normalmente es cuando uno agrega algo y
en realidad no exponer costos es poner
límites límites pero sin embargo todo el
mundo bueno ya yo puedo aportar algo
yo he escuchado en otros países
poco a poco muchos jóvenes en américa
latina por lo menos ya están usando ese
lenguaje y por favor no seamos viejos
aunque no tengamos más 17 años yo me
acuerdo que tenía 17 años y miraba a la
gente mayor que se rechazaban todo lo
que venía yo nunca sea como de ellos y
no seremos todos y podemos decir que la
academia piense lo que quiera y diga lo
que quiera nosotros acá en nuestro mundo
y media cuando me pongan la real
academia latinoamericana y veremos de
qué se trata pero además como dice pel
una vez que no quiero usar que use todos
y todos y todas y felicity todas y todos
es decir no impide que uno haga todos y
todos menos transitados que piensan de
ese debate sumar yo la verdad o sea la
real académia puede hacer lo que quiera
pero
la gente si la gente lo usa y aparte o
sea qué problema hay en hacer que la
gente se sienta más incluida si hay
gente que cuando uno usa todos se siente
más incluida y se siente mejor en
sociedad qué problema hay
y tú qué piensas de eso voy a usar
alguna palabra que utiliza
si la chs
[Risas]
y habla española
sería eso 'la academia' neologismo que
hay que proponerle a la cara para
molestarlos
la palabra
además de lo que acabamos de mencionar
pero empecemos con el día del hombre y
de la mujer existen los días es el día
del todo el día del día el hombre todos
los días esta semana un mensaje
felicidad el hombre existe
no esta semana fue feliz
así que el día de la mujer que no así yo
quiero destacar algo con estas
elecciones que hubo recientemente en
canadá destacar la el nombramiento de
crista freeland que era sé que era
ministra de relaciones exteriores de
canadá como viceprimera ministra
canadiense ese es un paso ya a ser
primera ministra ha existido antes ese
no existió y sólo hubo un primer
ministro que fue nombrado vice primer
ministro que fue electo primer ministro
y fue jan christian el único el único
por ejemplo estuvo la ministra también
liberales y la cob fue nombrada también
en un momento dado viceprimera ministra
pero nunca se candidateó fue elegida
primera ministro nuevo encargo estatuido
no porque la última vez que se nombró a
alguien yo creo que fue con cristian y
fue como hace 20 años
no se utilizó más esta figura entonces
todo ahora está haciendo por algo muy
simbólico le está dando un lugar más
elevado dentro de la jerarquía política
de lo del partido liberal y ya en pues
me parece que hay que destacar lo bueno
lo desagregamos y creo que es un
nombramiento justo porque ella pues en
tanto que ministra de relaciones
exteriores de canadá le ha tocado
manejar problemas complejos y bueno el
problema que tiene yo esté entrado en
este momento es bastante complejo con
respecto a las alcachofas y de alberta
entonces pues se necesita alguien que
quiera país en largo porque el país está
como dividido separado acuérdense que en
estas elecciones federales no hubo un
solo diputado elegido de la provincia de
alberta ni de la provincia de
saskatchewan ni uno del gobierno del
partido liberal del partido liberal
claro entonces claro se llevaron los
conservadores entonces si hay una
división en este momento y es justamente
cristal freeland
además ministra de asuntos
intergubernamentales la que va a tener
la difícil tarea de unificar vengar
mentar a canadá y otra cosa es paciencia
con respecto a cristian filial es que es
de origen de albert y no es de aquellos
de alberta entonces probablemente aunque
se presente una sin construcción siempre
se ha presentado como política del
mensuario no exactamente pero yo los
quería mente es de alberta y otra cosa
que me gustaría destacar con respecto al
nuevo gabinete es la llegada de pablo
rodríguez más como el líder
parlamentario por el gobierno de los
centro do es el primer latino que tiene
este puesto que también es un puesto muy
importante por pablo rodríguez que tiene
una larga impacto en tucumán o anuncios
argentinas entonces y que tiene una
larga carrera con el partido liberal que
ha hecho muchas cosas y bueno
independientemente desde sus visiones de
su partido político representa el primer
latinoamericano con un puesto tan
importante dentro del gobierno federal
canadiense y también me dieron el puesto
de
la orden de ocuparse de que también
tiene un lugarteniente que es
responsable de las relaciones entre el
gobierno federal y que ver exactamente
entonces si me están en estos cargos
yo tengo algo más
[Risas]
y es una noticia que viene el sitio de
radio canadá que me llamó la atención de
un hombre en dubai que se ganó una isla
frente a las costas de nueva escocia
así se sorteó la isla entonces resulta
que el banco el banco este este es un
muchacho joven de 27 años que hay lo
vemos en 100 mil 100 mil dólares y no no
no la compro sé eso esa parte de la isla
para el viaje y participo quizás para
que la visiten o para que tenga para
comprar el pasaje él nunca antes había
oído hablar de canadá o sea porque él
está en dubai
llegó chiquitito con la familia pero te
cuento la historia de su familia llegó a
dubai él creció en dubai es especialista
en juegos videos
y el dj toca en discotecas y en bares
estaba fue a su banco para todas las
transacciones que tiene que hacer y lo
inscribieron para un sorteo el tipo nos
había alguien cuál era el sorteo después
le dijeron que había quedado que había
sido elegido para el sorteo a canal para
los 18 finalizará isla kerby y los 18
finalistas entonces tuvieron que hacer
jugar a dados y finalmente se ganó la
isla ha dado el sí entonces yo me fui a
buscar en internet a ver si existía esa
isla no porque el tipo dice el canal y
conocí a la canadiense yo creo que la
casa mi casa más grande tiene dos
hectáreas
se encuentra a tres horas de halifax y
al parecer la fiebre del oro
algunas de 2.800 y no lo hizo que la
gente fuera a buscar oro por allá por
esos lugares del oro
esto es de varios me pareció curioso
esta noticia
pero yo quiero hacer una primavera
porque yo no sé es una persona que no es
canadiense puede comprar se hace una y
ganarse una isla que en ganarse lo que
se sí porque la isla
la isla el gobierno de nueva escocia y
fue el gobierno de nueva escocia el que
la puso en venta y al parecer esta
entidad bancaria la conafor y la sorteo
entre sus clientes y este fue este fue
el muchacho que se ganó la lista
entonces de una isla de dos puntos
hectáreas que se llama hole point o
hurricane
virtual
parece un holograma y entonces me
pareció curioso como idea yo sólo quería
comentar aquí ahora vamos a regresar a
nuestros invitados y vamos a comenzar
con una cámara wood mercado decíamos al
principio tú eres la directora general
de los encuentros internacionales del
documental de montreal en tanto que
presidenta
en tanto que director éste es tu cuarto
y quinto años como como directora
general y mi sexto año en rd m
- y cómo has encontrado esos cinco años
bueno lleno de altibajos es un trabajo
que demanda mucho de uno pero que
también tiene mucho o sea que da mucho
cuando uno ve el resultado desde tanto
trabajo en el festival como este año por
ejemplo cuando uno ve el público en las
salas cuando ve los directores que están
contentos porque pueden intercambiar con
el público o sea uno trabaja tanto todo
el año con algo que es un poco como
e intangible y cuando uno llega al
festival esto es muy tangible y de ver
que todo eso toma forma y que se arma
este festival es algo impresionante
increíble entonces el otro día estábamos
hablando que años de festivales son como
años perros que es como 5 años son como
10 años en realizar
bueno el festival comenzó el 14 de
noviembre y termina de este domingo
exacta 40 dinos cuál fue la película de
apertura y cuál será la película de
clausura del festival la película de
apertura fue ese pensar main matters de
benjamin o parece que es un italiano
abrió una primera película sobre la su
madre
benedetta bardini que se retiró de la
vida de uno en realidad que tiene como
un es una señora que fue cuando era
joven que fue modelo que fue top model y
todo y que tiene una idea
cambió completamente y se volvió
feminista socialista el profesor
etcétera y tiene esta relación hacia la
imagen y la imagen de la mujer
muy conflictivas entonces es una
película más bien sobre esta señora que
quiere desaparecer no necesariamente
morir pero desaparecen y dejar de tener
imágenes de ellas y ese hijo que quiere
filmar la entonces detención de los dos
y la clausura es una película canadiense
drake de miguel' weinberg
que sobre chicos que se disfrazan y
hacen rock soul entonces es una película
sobre en realidad niños y niñas que
quieren expresarse de otra manera que se
expresan a través de ese arte que es el
arte del drac y como encuentran
comunidades como encuentran un espacio
donde desarrollar su creatividad y su
personalidad a través de ese tipo de
muchas niños niñez exactamente
la niñez
porque yo le pongo los acentos donde me
da la gana
y así casi casi una verdad absoluta para
amar también y para ustedes este
festival le acoge a artistas de varias
lenguas películas y si tenemos en
realidad 154 películas de 47 países
diferentes y se hacen con la lengua si
viene de países que nos nos da siempre
buscamos películas que sean subtituladas
en francés o subtituladas en inglés y
díaz en un mundo ideal en los dos porque
cada película se presenta dos veces
entonces queremos habitualmente
presentarlo
una vez subtitulado en francés y otra en
inglés porque tenemos un público que es
muy bilingüe y es algo que para nosotros
es importante darle ese espacio a los
dos idiomas del país no y en estos cinco
años cinco años de festival o un poquito
más que es lo que descubriste algo
extraordinario que te haya realmente
tocado en términos de película en
términos de tal vez de una realizadora u
realizador algo que destacaron que es
difícil de en tu posición a diario
de eso pero siempre digo en cuanto a
emoción que haya ido a buscarte yo no
creo que pueda elegir como una película
una directora un director pero lo que sí
yo descubrí en los últimos seis años es
la comunidad documental nacional
internacional que o sea yo vengo del
cine de ficción y es una comunidad la
gente que trabaja en documental que es
muy diferente es una comunidad que se o
sea que trabajan todos y todas trabajan
juntos o sea es muy raro ver en cine de
ficción por ejemplo un director o una
directora que haga sonido en la película
de otra persona y que ayude en otras
cosas o que edite para otra persona y
que después dirija hay mucha
colaboración es el documental es una
industria
yo prefiero llamar la comunidad que se
ayuda mucho mucho entre ellos y también
es una comunidad que tiene mucho interés
hacia el otro hacia todo lo que tiene
que ver con política internacional todo
lo que tiene que ver con la sociedad
y eso para mí fue como el descubrimiento
de estos últimos seis años de conocer
poco a poco la gente que trabaja en
documental y que hace documental
y 154 películas seleccionar 154
películas se requiere tener todo un
equipo para poderlo hacer o sea nosotros
tenemos un directo director artístico
que es bueno de acá y él trabaja con un
equipo de 5 programadoras
que ven las películas con él tenemos
también un comité de preselección
entonces son muchas personas que se
ponen juntas para ver o sea las
sumisiones las películas que nos llegan
pero también para ir a otros festivales
y para ver las películas que nosotros
vamos a buscar oa casas de producción oa
otros festivales etcétera entonces es un
trabajo muy largo es un trabajo
complicado la gente siempre tiene o sea
la gente piensa que los programadores se
van a su sofá se miran sus películas y
esa siesta está buena la vamos a poner
pero en realidad hay una reflexión muy
profunda atrás del hecho de programar un
festival documental o un festival de
cine en general porque para que tener
una programación coherente y una
programación que represente la
producción del año y que represente bien
lo que es el documental hoy el día hoy
en día el lenguaje cinematográfico
detrás del documental hay muchos muchos
criterios a través de todo eso entonces
no es una cuestión de presentar las
mejores películas
año no son las películas que encajan
juntas este año son las películas que
hablan de una cosa que contestan otra
cosa que muestran un nuevo enfoque sobre
una temática específica
pregunta justamente en el sentido de la
coherencia hay un tema central que
escogen ustedes cada año en el que tiene
que converger las películas que eligen o
no porque el documental es es el reflejo
del mundo y el mundo va cambiando
entonces de decir este año la temática
es no sé las mujeres reduciría a los
hombres de sacar yo del lado claro
pobres hombres el nombre en realidad es
cortarse por ahí todo una parte de la
producción del año que por ahí no encaja
en esta temática y no vale la pena
porque el documental tiene que seguir
siendo el reflejo de lo que está pasando
en el mundo y de las preocupaciones de
los directores y las directoras entonces
es a nosotros lo bueno lo que hace el
equipo de programación es en realidad
mirar la producción de películas del año
y decir a estos son los temas que se
destacan y ahí formar obviamente que hay
temas que vuelven a cada año el medio
ambiente con los cambios climáticos las
cuestiones políticas en el medio oriente
las crisis sociales etcétera
queremos darnos esa libertad de poder
programar
en lo que pasa ese año y no tener como
una línea fija desde más recordar la
formación de la programación del uno de
los festivales más conocidos de montreal
festival de jazz de montreal que cuando
uno va lo menos que encuentra es jazz
porque no porque verdad o sea uno dice
el subjetiva el de jazz de montreal y
esto dos o tres números de ellas probé
en realidad es un festival de música en
este caso con el festival de
documentales donde se convergen en la
obra como tal y no necesariamente el
tema
hablando de cine justamente carlos tú
estás presentando en el marco de este
este vigésimo segundo
el año de los encuentros internacionales
del cine documental tu más reciente
documental que es el este sobre ser
young y que es un fotógrafo francés que
llegó aquí a canadá en 1975 estuve
viendo la película y hubo muchos
detalles que ya llamaron mi atención
entre otros que él nació el 8 de
diciembre de 1951 cuatro días antes que
yo
[Risas]
y el otro detalle es que llegó aquí en
1975 que fue el año en que yo llegué
aquí está casado con una señora que
pero la pregunta carlos es que te llegó
a ti en tanto que cineasta a interesarte
en este personaje fotógrafo que trabajó
para la federación de un sindicato acá
bueno yo quería decir antes que a mí me
parece que el tema de este año no es un
tema pero algo común es la inclusión y
me dio la impresión que había un
esfuerzo consciente por por escuchar las
voces de mucha gente diversa de varias
partes y no solamente de procedencias
sino de actitudes y de políticas y de
estéticas
y en realidad eso lo que me atrajo a mí
a tsonga que es un fotógrafo con los
conocidos
su padre era afroamericano pero del dedo
cuyana de guyana francesa él peleó en la
guerra por el lado de los franceses en
indochina que se le llamaba la que
habitualmente conoció a una mujer que
era europea o sea blanca que salía de
los campos de concentración nunca se
supo de donde tuvo los papeles de otra
persona y tuvieron un hijo que fue ser
hyung y que eventualmente emigró y sí
sobre todo propulsado por la tragedia de
la muerte de su madre que murió cuando
él tuvo seis años y nunca pudo
recuperarse en realidad y pasó todo el
resto de su vida tratando de recuperar
su esos momentos de felicidad una vida
atormentada vida atormentada dice el
padre quedó en marsella también se quedó
amargo con la muerte de su esposa que él
quería de verdad sería que era una
pareja muy hermosa
y yo creo que sé yo me imagino solo lo
que él debe haber sufrido como racismo
en la peleando por el lado de los
franceses y las atrocidades que se
cometieron en indochina es un hombre que
estaba golpeado el interesado por loco
intelectual que él inculcó a su hijo un
gusto por las artes y por las letras que
se nota en ese corto que es que cuando
vino con 75 trabajo por captan quebec
que era un programa para la televisión
que se ocupaba de la banda cine del
cómic
[Música]
yo tengo una pregunta estábamos
discutiendo del documental yo vi un
fragmento no todo con pablo
el personaje del documental en un
momento deja de ser yo hambre y es la
foto como tal o sea el leimotiv de él
con cómo se hace para construir una
historia a través de la narración de la
historia y las fotos
bien bravo ahora que hace una película
con fotos film sanz y que además son un
poco fuera de foco acierto pero
felizmente no solamente buen fotógrafo
era escritor también entonces toda la
película está guiada por sus propios
textos que son leídos por un gran poeta
de acá yo el de voz y en francés y que
lee sus textos y se se compenetró mucho
con con la imagen de jonge ellos dice lo
que no puedo fotografiar lo escribo
que me parece fantástico entonces eso te
llevo a
bueno tu película anterior fue un nudo
drama de walter benjamin y que también
fue un personaje muy atormentado
entonces como que sigues en esa línea tú
y gente que no creo pero también a mí lo
que me atrajo de jonge fue cuando vi una
exposición sobre el en el cual hablaba
de pasaporte de nomadismo de doctor de
huellas él se pasó la vida vibrando
entre los negros y los blancos la
américa europa el inglés el francés y
decía por favor a mí no me diga nadie
quién soy yo porque iba a la república
dominicano y lo trataban de blanco vine
acá y lo trataban de negro estaba harto
decía déjeme decir quién soy lo que yo
mismo lo digo
una frase muy interesante entre otras él
dice no es la búsqueda de la identidad
lo que me interesa sino como decirla o
cómo describir la identidad que es
justamente uno de los desafíos de
nosotros como inmigrantes acá cuando nos
pregunta de dónde eres entonces es como
describir nuestra identidad como que se
vuelve complicado en sí para la gente
más complicada para otro yo estoy
contento sentado entre dos tías pero
claro yo no yo soy blanco burgués y
hombre entonces tengo todo de mi lado
nosotros vamos en todo a favor entonces
no tengo inseguridades que me han sido
inculcados cuando eran niños lo único
que es fue inculcado a mí cuando yo era
niño era la curiosidad por el otro
porque vengo de un país que es indio
entonces el perú es un país solo solo
que le atrajo de walter benjamin porque
justamente eso que no se le puede hacer
como en facebook o así o así
pero que es un ametralladora que dice
hacia todos lados le interesaba la
política el marxismo el surrealismo la
fotografía mickey mouse primero a
traducir puesto si un gran francófilo de
baudelaire conocedor de pro de leer se
refugió en nueva york quienes no no no
en parís el otro grupo de la escuela de
frankfurt se fue a nueva york sí pero
eso es lo que me interesa gente que vive
que vibra entre varias cosas si leonardo
tenemos algún comentario de nuestros
oyentes y tenemos comentarios buenos
saludos de gilberto martínez saludos
desde nicaragua nos está escuchando
gustavo lucas nos dice saludos de la
ciudad de melo departamento desarrollar
en uruguay
aquí ya en veda electoral como ver
seguir decía hace un ratito no permito
me permitió comentar que en las últimas
encuestas indican un posible triunfo del
candidato de la coalición de derecha
luis lacalle
por el 51 5% respecto del candidato del
partido frente amplio actualmente en el
gobierno daniel martínez y uno que si
quieren el domingo les paso el informe
sí gracias por supuesto gustado
con un informe con lo que pasa
abajo y se olviden mencionar que el
porcentaje tuviera daniel martínez es el
44.5 por ciento una diferencia de siete
puntos entre ambos candidatos
carlos cuál fue el principal desafío
para hay un castigo para ti en tanto que
si ni hasta hacer esa película
hacer una película con foto fija es el
primer desafío pero felizmente yo estoy
muy muy atraído por la moda por la ottt
cuchillos por los efectos especiales por
la van de cine que le gustaba veo todas
las películas americanas por los efectos
no porque me abren una ventana a la
psicología del ser humano sino porque me
encanta la artesanía entonces el proceso
artesanal de hacer una película es algo
muy bonito y muy agradable y el desafío
principal era hacer una postura porque
lo conocimos el todo está animado pero a
la mano habla mucho de la computadora
pero todo está decidido por la mano
entonces es como coste puente esto se va
pensando exactamente en la traducción es
una colcha que se hace con pedacitos de
theresa nikkei que josé y los logra las
señoras en aquella época aquí en este
que ve que en el que nosotros vivimos
hacían esas colchas y las cocinan a mano
así lo hice yo fui una vez participe en
un taller de hacer conchitas de esas me
encantó es muy divertido es un grupo son
grupos de homosexuales es imperfecto
está lleno de amor es lo pueblo quieres
tocar para mí mi sueño es hacer una
película como esos libros para el niño
de poe para hacer una película cual te
puedes meter que te rodea completamente
en plasticina al nose psicotrópicas
[Risas]
[Música]
de estos cascos es lo que me hace
acordar eso fue una de una película no
me acuerdo
el autor ni el director pero la película
se llama synecdoche new york
era un murió el actor que el tipo ganaba
un premio y tenía que realizar su obra
de arte y lo que la sierra reproducía en
teatro su vida en tiempo real
y es una locura grave es una locura
synecdoche new york ha visto un hombre
sin director
es conocidísimo el director también de
los nuevos canales ves es lo bonito del
festival que escogen diferentes hay
variedad y en realidad para un director
partir en el rms es un trampolín
magnífico no porque es cada año mejora
su calidad y la gente toma atención lee
lo que ha sido ya escogido y puede parte
parte la cumbia cuando hay alegrías para
hablando justamente de los niños
latinoamericanos como que tal es la
participación diseña hasta
latinoamericana encontraron andy kaufman
y bueno los latinoamericanos que
establece la participación y mirar este
año creo que tenemos alrededor de nuevo
pero bien por qué pero creo 8 o 10
películas latinoamericanas
o sea incluyendo de una de ecuador un
cortometraje de ecuador que se llama la
balada de sandoval tenemos películas
chilenas tenemos películas de brasil
tenemos o sea películas mexicanas
también siempre méxico está súper bien
representado en la programación y bueno
después obviamente no es latino pero
tenemos también películas en español de
esparta entonces creo que para nosotros
hacia el festival siempre tuvo muy
buenos lazos con latinoamérica por una
cuestión creo de afinidad del pueblo de
que ve con todo lo que tiene que ver con
latinoamérica y también porque es un
cine que acá
en la gente le gusta le interesa y tiene
realidades que les interesa nuestro
público
y este año bueno especialmente estoy
pensando en la película la cordillera de
los sueños de patricio guzmán
que es súper importante con lo que está
pasando en este momento en chile que yo
creo que de ver es esa voz y es la
última película de su trilogía que
empezó hace tiempo y que la cordillera
de los sueños es sobre el legado o sea
la relación entre lo político y la
cordillera que siempre está ahí en
santiago y recordar en realidad la gente
que quedó después de la dictadura
exactamente en las relaciones los que se
fueron el maldito
la [ __ ] herencia de pinochet
pero para comprender chile hoy día hay
que ver esa película veo cordillera de
mis sueños muy fuerte
a nivel canadiense de provincia
la verdad es que para nosotros es súper
importante obviamente tener una muy
buena representación de las películas de
quebec porque estamos en quebec pero
también del resto de canadá yo creo que
a veces tenemos tendencia a caer en
montreal bien que venga un poco
olvidarnos de que existe el resto de
canadá pero en documental
específicamente hay muy buen cine que se
hace en canadá y que se hace en
diferentes idiomas no necesariamente en
inglés únicamente y creo que es
importante de representar también esa
producción cinematográfica y hoy porque
sólida de producción es de las primeras
naciones canadienses sí sí siempre
tenemos tenemos este año
willbold stand up de talla hardware que
es sobre el caso de un monto en euros y
muy buena película
tenemos la película una película de
alanis obomsawin
su película es exactamente y nosotros
tenemos una colaboración con un épico
inmóvil donde delante de todas las
películas de la competencia nacional se
presenta un cortometraje producido por
los jóvenes que trabajan como aquitaine
y hay una actividad súper interesante e
importante a mi juicio que es el premio
de las detenidas sigue sigue y sigue en
pie desde el 2012
o sea es un premio que se da con la
prisión de hoy estas seis mujeres que
ven las películas de la competencia
nacional y dan un premio
por primera vez no no no desde el 2012
desde el 2012 entonces papi y bueno pues
le permite a estas mujeres también que
están es lo que me parece genial entre
otras cosas que están encarceladas de
salirse de alguna forma de de ese mundo
en el que se encuentran y el cotidiano
en una cárcel y el mundo también no sea
el programa en cárceles se pensó también
porque nosotros creemos que el
documental participa de la educación y
de la formación de ser un ciudadano y de
vivir en sociedad y creo que muchas
veces en las cárceles uno piensa nada
más en lo punitivo y que no después esas
personas salen y han estado en una
especie de burbuja donde
no necesariamente avanzan como humanos
desde ir y presentar documental les
permite si obviamente salir de la cárcel
pero también les permite reflexionar
sobre ellos mismos reflexionar sobre lo
que está pasando en el mundo y es como
también una correa de transmisión entre
el mundo exterior y lo que ellos están
viviendo ellas están viviendo adentro de
una pregunta para yo sé que vos naciste
acá tu historia es un poco tal vez
diferente de carlos que te que te trajo
acá
carlos desde perú cuál es tu historia
con este tipo de películas que haces
debe haber algo interesante y ella vivió
en europa en eeuu y en el perú
no tuve la fuerza para quedarme en el
perú en europa estaba triste todos los
días y en eeuu están locos
[Risas]
cuánto tiempo viviste en perú en total
debido unos 25 años
de acuerdo y en canadá más de 35
ah caramba si no lo hace 50 años clavos
yenes
ahí está la historia perú canadá
entonces sí y acá es el paraíso para
hacer cine comparado con cualquier otro
país del mundo además al que huyó horas
en la cine que yo creo que ninguna otra
parte además a la gente le encanta el
cine y como la literatura no es el
espejo de esta sociedad es el cine que
se ha vuelto su espejo y si quisieran
ser el sitio documental porque el cine
de ficción que ve con el canadiense es
un cine de ficción que se concentra nada
más que en la mayoría en la mayoría sí y
que no es representativo de lo que
muchos de los medios de comunicación
canadienses en general
5 leonardo aquí tenemos conoces a
rodríguez charlize nos contacta de
votación los viernes nos dice como los
paisajes de parís a los de la vida en
benjamín en algún momento no está
hablando y puso ese comentario lo acabo
de ver y césar rodríguez dice después
pide permiso en realidad puede copiar me
la idea de hacer una película con
fotografías porque él es un amante de la
radio
el fotógrafo también así que todo el
tiempo pasa como agua entre los dedos no
sé si pueden resaltar los temas pero muy
rápido
paloma tú bueno yo hice esta semana un
reportaje basado en los nuevos datos de
estadísticas canadá con respecto a los
estudios de los inmigrantes y los hijos
de inmigrantes en particular y resaltan
en este estudio que los hijos de
inmigrantes si estudian más pero que los
latinos hijos de inmigrantes
latinoamericanos estudian menos y ganan
menos en canadá particularmente entonces
los invito a que vean el reportaje en
nuestro sitio internet www.dgt.es una
mega investigación llevada a cabo por
médicos especializados de la provincia
de ontario y de la provincia de alberta
sobre 5 un poco más de 5 millones de
canadienses que tuvieron cáncer en un
periodo de 45 años
la buena noticia es que los cánceres en
gente mayor mayor de 50 años están
disminuyendo pero esto aumenta la malas
noticias que está aumentando entre los
jóvenes entonces hay que ir un poco y a
ver de qué se tratan porque y hay qué
tipos de cánceres están aumentado eres
en el punto sea leonardo que menos
humedad del granero del mundo hay oro
para ello software exacto en granero del
mundo en el ártico que pone lo que hace
justamente juntarse viena de todo el
mundo por las dudas de que haya un
apocalipsis bueno en este caso una
empresa propiedad de microsoft están
generando esto que es llamado el hit hit
hub arctic code o arctic program que es
para guardar todos los códigos abiertos
de que existen en el mundo por las dudas
de que haya un arma
a los lados que estaba haciendo esto
pero no todas las lenguas le dije y si
nos vamos a usar muy rápidamente yo los
invito a escuchar una entrevista que
hice con un cineasta que participa en el
festival se llama saúl cac y su película
se llama los los ecos del volcán
entonces para más detalles tienen que ir
a nuestro sitio para ver ese para que
escuchen en la entrevista y lo que él
dice sobre esos ecos del volcán
muchísimas gracias maras bus mercado
muchísimas gracias carlos ferrando hasta
ahora verde venido hasta aquí hasta
nuestros estudios y aquí al equipo
[Música]
muchísimas gracias y adiós a todas sus
felicidades
[Música]
aquí